it's not working for the majority of of
people yeah and you say too that uh our
socioeconomic Mobility has dropped like
a stone where you imagine that this is a
country where you can move between
quintiles and it really hasn't been true
for a while and it's an engineer I view
it as an engineering problem right so
because profitability
has a cycle
that doesn't
um necessarily
achieve the goal fully
uh it's wonderful things about it but at
the same time
capitalism as it creates big differences
those it those reinforce each other so
um if you have a lot of money your kids
get a good education
if you don't and you're pulling poverty
they don't get a good education
um or you have more power or those
things and also ironically you get more
indebted the country becomes more
indebted and and if you look at the
assets and liabilities if you're richer
you can borrow money and that's why I
like to support micro Finance but anyway
if you're richer you can borrow money
and you own stocks and bonds and when
the Federal Reserve buys stocks and
bonds for monetary policy purposes you
get more Rich relative to others and so
there are engineering reasons that are
um that exist and if they were modified
um it would improve incentives it would
improve productivity people think it's
just a wealth transfer no no it's a
productivity trap yeah it's actually
just trying to improve the engineering